un incontournable des visites
culturelles à faire dans les Yvelines ou
même en Île-de-France plus largement le
parc France Miniature ouvre ses portes
ce samedi 8 avril pour en parler avec
nous Marianne Edwige alors je le répète
vous êtes la responsable communication
du site située à Élancourt et avant de
commencer j'aimerais faire un petit tour
de plateau est-ce que vous êtes déjà
rendu à France Miniature oui moi j'ai
emmené mes enfants et très longtemps
en revanche j'ai oui dire que France
Miniature était implantée à Élancourt si
je me trompe pas mais qu'elle est en
cours n'était pas représentée dans
France Miniature est-ce que c'est vrai
est-ce que c'est faux
dans tous les villages de France il y a
un petit monument il suffit de chercher
c'est vrai que par contre on n'a pas
représenté Élancourt
la particularité du parc c'est qu'on a
représenté tous les monuments ou un 30e
donc pour pour vous présenter puisque je
ne l'avais pas visité encore mais je
vais vous renvoyer une invitation
évidemment
on a vraiment représenté sur cinq
hectares en forme de carte de France un
grand jardin en forme de carte de France
117 monuments qui sont au 1/30 donc on a
une tour Eiffel qui fait 10 mètres on a
un château de Chambord qui fait à peu
près un mètre 50 le château de
Versailles qui s'étend sur plus de 150
m² au sol avec les jardins et les
bâtiments et France Miniature c'est
vraiment une balade à faire qu'on soit
grand ou petit on va tous piocher des
choses différentes des souvenirs ou des
envies de découvertes aussi beaucoup de
magie c'est très ludique il y a des
petits trains qui circulent on découvre
de région en région tout ce qu'il y a de
plus joli de connus ou de moins connus
et vraiment je vous invite à à venir
nous voir à partir de ce samedi
puisqu'on ré-ouvre ce samedi oui vous
rouvrir en grande pompe si j'ose dire
puisque vous allez ouvrir avec un
monumental jeu de piste à l'occasion
de Pâques c'est Pâques et pour pas que
on aime bien chasser les oeufs donc on a
conçu conçu un parcours pour les
familles qui a un parcours d'observation
on va pas proposer à nos visiteurs de de
rentrer dans les maquettes mais
simplement de faire une balade et
d'observer au détour des allées des
monuments et des mises en scène des
petits œufs factices qu'on a caché des
petits sujets lapins pouls etc on leur
raconte une petite histoire de Pâques on
fournit à tous nos visiteurs quand ils
arrivent un petit livret dans lequel il
va falloir repérer des indices tout au
long du parcours et à la fin de la
visite si on a bien tout trouvé et même
si on n'a pas tout trouvé on récupère
des petites récompenses qui sont elles
vraiment chocolatées il y aura quand
même des vrais chocolats à déguster ça
vous donne peut-être envie de d'y
retourner avec vos enfants que c'était
soit un petit peu grand pour ça je vous
remercie avec mes petits-enfants
peut-être avec vos petits-enfants plus
grands donc ça va faire en famille
plutôt à faire en famille on a aussi
beaucoup d'adultes qui viennent seuls se
balader pour découvrir
les monuments et le patrimoine quand on
est avec des petits enfants il y a aussi
tout un tas de petites attractions et de
lieu d'interaction où on peut jouer avec
le paysage on va apprendre comment
fonctionne une écluse par exemple on va
pouvoir manipuler les vitraux de la
cathédrale de Chartres avec un gros
puzzle en 3D qui est à l'extérieur de la
maquette donc ce qu'on a voulu proposer
à nos visiteurs c'est vraiment d'aller
du nord au sud et d'est en ouest de voir
tout le parcours toute la carte de
France mais en s'amusant et on
permettant aux petits de aussi découvrir
des choses dans les régions et de pas
être simplement spectateurs oui c'est ce
qui fait aussi un peu l'ADN de France
Miniature c'est de proposer des
attractions et puis des expériences
interactives on a Fort Boyard depuis
l'année dernière on a Koh-Lanta c'est ce
qui fait un peu la l'identité de France
Miniature alors on a voulu aussi salut
le patrimoine télévisuel avec ces deux
grosses émissions qui réunissent
beaucoup les familles qui sont des
emblématiques et puis qui ont des
valeurs de du défi du challenge du jeu
avec Koh-Lanta l'année dernière on a
souhaité proposer quelque chose de
rafraîchissant avec une zone aqualudique
l'idée c'est vraiment de proposer à nos
visiteurs quand ils viennent à France
Miniature de passer du bon temps
ensemble d'échanger de partager et
souvent quand on passe du bon moment bah
c'est en riant beaucoup
en découvrant en apprenant et adultes
qu'on soit maman ou mamie on a toujours
plaisir à transmettre et à raconter des
histoires aussi à notre entourage donc
c'est ce qu'on fait à France Miniature
alors ça vous a donné envie d'y aller
je suis conquis voilà pour aller
retrouver le lapin de Pâques peut-être
alors votre monument français miniature
préféré Marianne edwire si vous deviez
en choisir un dans le parc c'est lequel
c'est la question difficile celle-là
puisque je j'en aime beaucoup je dois
dire qu'il y en a un que j'ai eu envie
d'aller voir en vrai il y a pas très
très longtemps ça doit faire trois
étrange et organisé mes vacances dans
cette région pour le voir en vrai c'est
la cathédrale Sainte-Cécile d'Alby dans
le Tarn qui est une cathédrale qui est
colossale majestueuse en brique rouge et
qui est très grosse en maquette dans le
parc et j'avais très envie de l'avoir en
vrai donc celle-ci c'est un joli
souvenir mais j'en ai plein et alors
hormis ce jeu de piste sur pack et sur
cette chasse aux œufs est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres actualités à venir à France
Miniature alors on vous dévoilera la
semaine prochaine une nouveauté qu'on
est en train de finaliser ça va être un
parcours immersif sur le thème de la
France des légendes où on va proposer à
nos visiteurs de ces garer quelque part
dans la forêt de Brocéliande de
rencontrer des créatures et des
personnages avec pas toujours de très
bonnes intentions on sera guidé par la
méchante fémorgane dans cette aventure
et on vous en dit plus la semaine
prochaine et bien on a hâte de découvrir
tout ça merci beaucoup Marian ne Edwig
d'avoir été avec nous en plateau pour
répondre à nos questions alors pour
rappel la réouverture du parc France
Miniature c'est ce samedi 8 avril à 10h
vous retrouverez plus d'informations sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran